[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la escalada de tensión entre rusia y
ucrania un escenario donde ahora mismo
está centrada la diplomacia mundial nos
acompañan en este estudio fernando
avakian especialista del espacio
postsoviético y es consultor ante la
unesco bienvenido fernando bien muchas
gracias por tenerme aquí invitado rafael
caña es mi compañero delegado de efe en
parís es corresponsal en bruselas en
washington en nueva york y en pekín
bienvenido rafael muchas gracias carlos
y en dúplex desde moscú nuestro
corresponsal saber con las xavier buenos
días los días
encantado de estar aquí para explicar lo
que ocurre entre rusia y ucrania la
escalada de tensión entre rusia y
ucrania hoy nuestro asunto en primera
plana
se están preparando las fuerzas rusas
para la guerra en ucrania ese es sin
duda el miedo entre los líderes
occidentales y la propia ucrania y una
pregunta que lleva planeando ya desde
hace algunas semanas hace sólo siete
años o sea se apoderó de parte de
ucrania y apoyó a los separatistas que
iniciaron un conflicto en grandes áreas
del este rusia se ha resistido durante
mucho tiempo al acercamiento de ucrania
de las instituciones europeas y su
demanda clave es que nunca se una a la
otan ni tenga infraestructura de la otan
en su territorio no hay una sensación de
una amenaza inminente pero en esta
escalada hay muchas aristas muchos
planos que analizar con rusia y eeuu y
europa de tercera en discordia y
buscando un poco su sitio en este
rompecabezas diplomático del que muchos
hacen ya la liaison con la guerra fría
analicemos algunas portadas que nos deja
la prensa diario le monde o titulada
esta semana ucrania y otan semana
decisiva entre washington y moscú
el wall street journal destacaba las
posiciones alejadas que han mantenido
eeuu y rusia en las conversaciones sobre
ucrania el país rusia advierte a eeuu de
que pone en peligro la seguridad europea
bueno un imprevisible presidente ruso
acumula miles de soldados en la frontera
de un país vecino de ucrania amenazas
más o menos vídeos y miles de invasión
una posible conflagración entre
occidente y oriente y mucho juego de
equilibrios no sé si tienen la sensación
fernando de que esto se parece a la
guerra fría
personalmente siempre me abstengo un
poco a trazar paralelismos y tan fuertes
para con momentos históricos anteriores
porque siempre hay digamos cuestiones de
fondo que necesariamente van cambiando
no estamos en la guerra fría ciertamente
en mi opinión en mi opinión estamos más
bien asistiendo a un esquema clásico
desde el punto de vista del paradigma
realista de las relaciones
internacionales a un escenario clásico
en el cual una potencia una
superpotencia y digámoslo rusia está
marcando a través de
la amenaza del uso de la fuerza
cuáles son las líneas rojas para que el
contrincante por así decirlo en este
caso occidente general pero eeuu en
particular no tiene que atravesar yo
creo que es más una cuestión de amenaza
que de posibilidad real de guerra es
pero verdaderamente no equivocarme pero
me parece más bien que es una especie
como de
muestra de hasta dónde puede llegar
rusia en este caso es decir si vamos a
trazar la los paralelismos para con no
la guerra fría sino con lo que ocurrió
en 2014-2015 con la anexión de crimea y
la guerra en el donbass hay cosas muy
distintas primero principal la reacción
de crimea por parte de rusia y la guerra
híbrida en el donbass
fueron completamente por sorpresa rusia
en ningún momento dejó entrever cuáles
eran digamos las vías de acción que iba
a tomar en este caso rusia está
básicamente mostrando poniendo sus
peones en el tablero está mostrando que
fuerzas iría utilizar de qué forma iría
a atacar
entonces me parece a mí que en un
momento tan decisivo es más bien una
demostración de fuerzas que otras no se
coincide rafa con el diagnóstico esos
paralelismos más o menos bien traídos
entre la guerra fría y la actuación en
la situación actual yo creo que
efectivamente no hay que hacer
continuamente paralelismos con
situaciones pasadas pero es inevitable
ver un poco de
muchas situaciones que se vieron durante
la guerra fría en el que las dos grandes
superpotencias la antigua unión
soviética y
eeuu
dentro del tablero de ajedrez que era el
mundo y su competencia que hacían por
conseguir escenas en zonas de influencia
y combatir los intentos del rival de
conseguir a su vez otras esferas de
influencia iban marcándose
líneas rojas o supuestas líneas rojas
iban marcándose faroles de
poker y
en este caso yo creo que rusia
aprovechando su estatus de gran potencia
militar no tanto económica pero
aprovechando su enorme alzarse en al
militar
y su disuasión nuclear aunque no
evidentemente no no la vaya a usar pero
es una gran potencia nuclear pues quiere
seguir jugando en él al nivel de las
grandes potencias y luego les quiero
preguntar por vladimir putin o mejor
dicho si sheen vladimir putin estaríamos
hablando de lo mismo vamos en este punto
de todas formas a moscú con nuestro
corresponsal saber colas para que nos
explique lo primero de toda esa obsesión
de rusia para que ucrania no entre en la
otan xavier que factores históricos
políticos y económicos hacen que ucrania
ser tan importante para moscú se puede
hablar mucho del pasado común que tienen
en rusia y ucrania aunque a día de hoy
están mucho más dispuestos a hablar de
ello rusia que los ucranianos pero sí
que hay que tener en cuenta lo que está
diciendo al mismo rusia las razones que
rusia está subiendo en concreto vladimir
putin habla de razones actuales pero
también como dije se habla de razones
existen razones ancladas en el en el
pasado y las principales que están
recordando ahora rusia son precisamente
que ucrania está hecha de trozos según
la versión de moscú que rusia fue
aportando a los de la historia con lo
cual ha recibido varios regalos esos
regalos son en el fondo también una
trampa porque es una de las fundamentos
para que rusia considere que ucrania no
es 100% soberana es una de sus zonas de
influencias es un producto de la unión
soviética y rusia se considera moscú se
considera la heredera de la universidad
tica no sólo piensa eso moscú también la
considera así eeuu desde el principio
por eso entre otras cosas el dedo
precisamente moscú el arsenal nuclear
que tenían otros países por ejemplo
ucrania así que en esa difícil coyuntura
histórica que fue el siglo 20 han
quedado como podemos ver algunas
semillas para que ni siquiera hoy rusia
y ucrania se pongan de acuerdo sobre que
son cada una hablantes fernando de las
líneas rojas que establece la la
principal es que la otan no tenga
infraestructura en ucrania esa sería
digamos la principal línea roja en la
fijación sí sí sí
en realidad hemos visto en el 2008 con
la guerra en georgia hasta donde estaba
dispuesto a llegar rusia para evitar que
un país el fronterizo a un nuevo país
fronterizo a rusia entra en la otan es
decir la guerra del 2008 en georgia fue
una demostración de fuerza como diciendo
ustedes han atravesado esta línea roja y
va a haber consecuencias hubo
consecuencias en el caso de ucrania en
el 2014 fue una demostración bastante
marcada de hasta dónde puede llegar
rusia entonces lo que ahora está
haciendo moscú me parece es
elevar un poco más el tono de
la respuesta
pero una vez más repito yo creo que
rusia tiene tanto para perder y tampoco
para ganar en una nueva guerra para con
ucrania y una guerra que no sé que no se
llevaría a cabo en regiones
rusoparlantes o que como crimea habían
tenido un caso histórico fuerte para con
rusia
y una vez más espero no equivocarme
que resulta como un jugador de poker
justamente que está tratando de asustar
al enemigo tratando como de hacer subir
las apuestas y ver de qué forma el
contrincante va a responder en esta
partida de poker a la que se refiere a
fernando claro hablamos de rusia y el
otro lado claro tenemos occidente y esta
crisis vuelve a poner en tela de juicio
varias cosas ha vuelto a poner en el
punto de mira la otan en particular dos
años después de que el presidente mamá
cron la definirá como en estado de
muerte cerebral del lado de eeuu parece
que la idea no tiene muchas ganas de
conflicto y del lado de la unión europea
volvimos siempre al punto de la voz
común de como articular una voz común no
rafael todas las piezas hay del otro
lado
si aquí hay mucho que tratar por un lado
es cierto que el presidente va a ir en
eeuu no tiene muchas ganas de conflicto
pero también es cierto que después de
que la administración de donald trump
era demasiado según sus críticos
demasiado
permisiva con rusia y con vladimir putin
ser entre comillas duro con rusia y
computing a nivel interno en eeuu es
rentable políticamente claro y entonces
tener un
mínimo de dureza frente a moscú a biden
le viene bien más ahora en momentos en
que a nivel interno por cuestiones de
asuntos de leyes que no avanzan en el
congreso y otras cosas a nivel doméstico
pues un empujoncito
político exterior le podría venir bien a
nivel europeo es cierto hay una
tradicional desunión en la unión europea
se habla mucho de voz común ayer en la
reunión de ministros euros de la unió
europea
a quien presta en francia se insistió
una nueva una nueva vez una nueva
ocasión en tener una voz común en todo
este esta crisis pero es cierto que a
los europeos les cuesta mucho tener una
voz común porque
la unión europea- sus miembros
más orientales han sido parte de la
antigua unión soviética como las
repúblicas bálticas o parte del pacto de
varsovia sobre todo polonia es la voz
más fuerte y
desconfían al cien por cien de moscú
porque han sido objeto de
diversos ataques informáticos o de
desinformación no hace mucho en lo
cierto es que se ha planteado un listado
de exigencias en las conversaciones en
ginebra bastante de bastante alto alto
alcance esto sería un buen termómetro de
la posición de fuerza de louboutin ahora
mismo este listado tan voy a hacer una
comparación había dicho el principio el
programa que no me gustan las
comparaciones un poco tiradas de otros
momentos históricos pero simplemente a
título vemos como caricatura en la época
de la guerra fría los momentos en los
cuales rusia tenía perdón la unión
soviética concretamente el kremlin tenía
un discurso más agresivo en el planeta
eran los momentos en los cuales a nivel
nuclear se encontraba más debilitada
vis-à-vis de eeuu por el contrario en
los momentos los cuales rusia
una vez más perdón el kremlin tenía una
fuerza relativamente un poco más
superior en términos nucleares a
washington la retórica se calma un poco
entonces no sé si
verdaderamente la subida de tono
realmente refleja
una nueva relación de fuerzas porque
rusia es decir necesita en alguna media
europa del mismo modo que europa
necesita a rusia y no sé en qué momento
podemos abordar la cuestión y lo vamos a
abordar seguir antes tengo que hacer una
pequeña pausa ya sea volvemos aquí en
primera plana hasta ahora
reporteros el programa de reportajes de
france 24 descubra las historias de la
gente con nuestros reporteros por todo
el planeta
y nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre
la noticia para contársela cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se la pierda
reporteros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
sus historias inspiran el futuro su día
a día es la actualidad su cultura sus
luchas sus éxitos y están en el corazón
de nuestros programas
descontamos los que hicieron américa
latina y los que la construyen hoy les
contamos un mundo hecho día a día por
los que lo habitan liberté égalité
actual y ti
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
analizando la crisis de ucrania lo
hacemos con fernando avakian
especialista del espacio postsoviético
rafael cañas delegado de efe en parís y
en dúplex desde moscú nuestro
corresponsal
xavier colás vamos con xavier porque
rusia aspira a modelar el futuro de la
otan amenaza con respuestas militares y
al mismo tiempo moscú dice que no
prepara otra invasión en este gran
entramado de diplomacia y amenazas y
concesiones que hablábamos antes con con
fernández con rafael xavier cuáles son
los objetivos últimos de vladimir putin
y como los embarcamos en la visión que
tiene del futuro de rusia la amenaza de
invasión tiene algún fundamento real que
podríamos considerar cuando rusia dice
que no quiere que la otan avance más
hacia el este y que se metan antiguos
territorios del pacto de varsovia
está chocando una realidad de hechos
consumados porque ya prácticamente todos
esos países están dentro de la otan por
supuesto que es una línea roja tal vez
precisamente porque esto lo que todavía
no se ha hecho cuando vladimir putin
plantea que no avance la otan más hacia
el este fundamentalmente se está
recibiendo a ucrania pero a día de hoy
todo el mundo sabe que no hay una
invitación formal para que ucrania entre
la otan es decir no hay un plazo todavía
de tiempo aunque ni es un estado
asociado
digamos que colabora con la alianza
atlántica y eso parece que pone nerviosa
a rusia probablemente porque ucrania con
el paso del tiempo
han pasado años desde aquella guerra que
nos sorprendió a todos en el año 2014 ha
ido modernizando su ejército y ha ido
acercándose de una manera podemos decir
extraoficial a eeuu y a la otan es decir
sin formar parte cada vez hay más
colaboración y esto parece que es el que
es algo que preocupa mucho en moscú a
medio plazo hablemos de la figura de
putin en todo esto cuáles serían los
objetivos últimos de putin y cómo nos
embarcamos en la visión que tiene del
futuro de rusia no sé si formulando la
pregunta de otra forma hasta qué punto
la figura de putin es clave en esta
crisis o mejor dicho sin putin
estaríamos hablando de la misma crisis
rafael
yo creo que no creo que
putin tiene
una imagen de sí mismo como
como el líder que
resucitó en
parte a la antigua urss como el salvador
de rusia no olvidemos que cuando él
llega al poder a principios de siglo
rusia estaba en una gravísima crisis
económica y de liderazgo porque con
boris yeltsin el país iba iba en declive
y se había entre comillas permitido la
entrada de todos muchos de los antiguos
países del pacto de varsovia en la otan
incluso de las tres repúblicas bálticas
y había una crisis económica muy muy
fuerte entonces
[Música]
a través también de gestos como la
recuperación del himno nacional
soviético
putin juega a intentar devolver la la
grandeza y el estatus de gran potencia
que se hace respetar en el a nivel
mundial
no sé si quieres añadir algo más
fernando a la figura de putin a la
figura de putting si se le atribuye la
frase a aquel que no tiene nostalgia de
la unión soviética no tiene corazón al
subir o aquel que quiere que vuelve a la
unión soviética no tiene cerebro en
alguna medida la frase es simplemente
para
estoy de acuerdo con él que dice rafa es
decir quiere tener esta imagen de sí
mismo como aquel que devolvió la
grandeza rusia y en alguna medida en
términos internacionales es cierto que
tras el impasse de los años noventa
logró volver a poner a rusia en la mesa
entre comillas de los grandes
el problema que tenemos los medios de
comunicación es que cuando hay una
crisis ponemos el foco y después pues a
veces desaparecen o algo que pasó con la
guerra de ucrania durante la guerra de
ucrania y la anexión rusa de crimea el
foco mediático estuvo allí puesto pero
como suele pasar muchas veces durante
los últimos años se ha ido diluyendo
xavier colás moscú es importante que
conozcamos cómo ha sido la evolución de
las situaciones de donbass durante los
últimos años hasta llegar a este punto
nos tenemos que retratar precisamente al
2014 que es cuando se produce esa
rebelión contra quien en don más
alentada armada y pagada en buena medida
por rusia pero entonces sucede algo muy
importante que es que rusia aunque con
hecho respalda a los rebeldes
jurídicamente no reconoce esos
territorios como un país que es lo que
ellos querían ser y sobre todo no
decidió incorporar esa región de donbass
a rusia como si ocurrió por ejemplo en
el caso de crimea y esa es una de las
razones para mí la principal por la cual
bombas sigue estando hoy en tierra de
nadie porque mucha gente votó a favor de
separarse de ucrania en esta región para
formar parte de rusia no tanto porque
echas de menos rusia porque hace
muchísimo tiempo que esos territorios no
forman parte de rusia no hay nadie vivo
que pueda recordar eso pero sí porque
echaban de menos la unión soviética la
principal apuesta a futuro de rusia para
ucrania lo que ellos propusieron en la
mesa de negociación es que hubiese una
especie de excederá realización es decir
que hubiese una descentralización del
poder y que esos territorios quedasen
dentro de rusia pero con una importante
autonomía que en un momento pareció
estar de acuerdo pero quiere antes
recuperar
esos territorios de hecho es decir poder
controlar lo que está pasando ahí y que
rusia no lo pueda hacer y esa es la
discusión que sigue bloqueando el asunto
a día de hoy
putin busca reconfigurar las fronteras
europeas de la posguerra fría al
establecer una amplia zona de seguridad
dominada por ruso y volver a traer a
ucrania a la órbita de moscú si fuera
necesario pues por la fuerza que puede
salir de este pulso en esa
reconfiguración con una europa si no se
coincide es rafa ninguneada por putin a
la hora de establecer el interlocutor
eeuu hablamos de seguridad europea y
europa es ninguneada
es cierto
rusia ha intentado
dividirla
[Música]
a la unión europea
para evitar que sea un frente unido en
su contra que se pueda liar con
eeuu por ejemplo
hasta ahora con el gobierno los
gobiernos de angela merkel ha tenido un
gran aliado a través de los acuerdos
estratégicos para la venta de gas el
gasoducto nord stream 2
y está por ver qué va a ocurrir ahora
con el nuevo gobierno alemán
pero de hecho en el anterior gobierno el
último gobierno socialdemócrata de
gerhard schröder antes de merkel también
había una gran apuesta a favor del gas
ruso y de hecho hubo muchas críticas
porque
trabajando en gazprom entonces hay que
ver un poco cómo es la postura alemana
la los europeos del este como ya hemos
dicho son desconfían mucho de moscú
también porque la agresividad de moscú
hace que no puedan olvidar ni tengan
ningún tipo de melancolía respecto a la
era soviética y hacia occidente
el occidente de europa abre a europa
occidental y francia intenta mantener
una voz propia a favor del diálogo con
moscú
y entonces si hay una cierta división
es difícil que europa pueda tener una
voz única
en este tema a medias y también lo hemos
visto cuando putin intenta saltar a
europa y hablar directamente con eeuu no
solamente por una cuestión de
relación de fuerzas duras es decir eeuu
con su ejército rusia con su ejército
sino más bien también para intentar
saltear en los obstáculos
institucionales
que pueden surgir a través de una
discusión en interno en la unión europea
cuáles son estos obstáculos
institucionales el veto a la oposición
permanente de los países bálticos que
tiene el mismo poder de voto que francia
o alemania o polonia
entonces le conviene más bien e intentar
saltearse europa o intentar tener
diálogos bilaterales como por ejemplo
con con alemania o con el sector privado
europeo
hace poco se cumplieron los 30 años a
todo esto del final de la urss y la
actualidad nos ha servido las nuevas
crisis de repúblicas como ucrania
kazajistán lo recordamos hace poco que
memorias avícolas moscú se guardan en la
rusia actual de la urss y como ha sido
el tratamiento oficialista de la
efeméride
alguna vez se le ha atribuido a vladimir
putin esa frase de quien que no quiere
de menos la unión soviética no tiene
corazón y quién no quien pretenda
repetirla no tiene cerebro entre los
rusos
hay un en algunos casos no en todos pero
en muchos rusos un sentimiento de
nostalgia y de echar de menos la unión
soviética pero alejado seguramente de lo
que es la ideología comunista no
significa que los rusos quieren repetir
en un gobierno pues que no contemple la
propiedad privada ni los derechos
individuales pero sí de aquel país de la
unión política como país no como sistema
sino como país un país muchísimo más
grande que ahora un país poderoso que
hablaba de tú a tú a eeuu entonces el
asunto de la unión política sigue
estando muy presente en la discusión
política en rusia aunque sea de manera
tácita aunque sea sin nada sin hablarlo
porque cada vez
vladimir putin presenta como un éxito
que estén volviendo a hablar de tu alto
con estados unidos que estén conteniendo
a eeuu que estén pensando digamos en las
negociaciones con la otan se está
refiriendo a volver a encontrar este
paraíso perdido que fue desde el punto
de vista geopolítico que fue la unión
soviética
bueno no me resisto tampoco en trasladar
la misma pregunta a fernando qué bueno
conocer perfectamente rusia que memoria
se guardián se guarda en la rusia actual
a nivel de calle de aquella época de la
urss
es muy interesante ver de qué forma
se ve el pasado como es decir no se
extrañen como estaba diciendo nicolás no
es extraño el comunismo se extraña las
cosas que se tenían digamos en la época
del comunismo no es queremos recrear la
unión soviética sino queremos una vez
más tener la estabilidad económica la
seguridad económica que cierta clase
media podría tener en la época soviética
que y luego en la década de los 90
la población de rusia y de todo el
espacio postsoviético se vio
traumatizada por la crisis económica
política hasta incluso identitaria
entonces es justamente lo que intentan
hacer es volver a ver a ese pasado de
antes de la década de los 90 recordando
eso no el comunismo no la vuelta a los
soviets pero sin la necesidad de una
estabilidad económica y en ese sentido
es muy rentable digamos por parte de
putin explotar esa es esa sensación
pues me quedo sin tiempo para más ha
sido un placer haberles tenido hoy
conmigo aquí en este programa analizando
la crisis de ucrania gracias fernando
gracias rafael gracias javier desde
moscú ya todos ustedes les esperamos
aquí en primera plana el próximo viernes
la de francia internacional y france 24
gracias
[Música]